Chris Mannix covers boxing and of course
the NBA for Yahoo Sports in the vertical
but we just had our a little wani on of
course covers MMA and he said it's crazy
for anybody to be talking about this
possibility of conor mcgregor vs floyd
mayweather where do you stand on this
nonsense but i would completely agree I
mean this is like a a celebrity trying
to boost his profile by bragging about
somebody he wants to date you know it's
it's Mayweather who is trying to remain
relevant as his career passes by by
mentioning McGregor and McGregor who
certainly has a lot more to gain because
of the value of a paycheck that comes
with Floyd Mayweather not doing the same
but you know Mayweather Dan is his he
and his team are probably the most
difficult group of people to negotiate
with the second most difficult I would
argue is probably Dana White with the
UFC and his team so logistically doesn't
work moreover it would be the most
aesthetically displeasing fight that
you've ever seen Conor McGregor has zero
boxing skills he would get completely
white washed by Floyd Mayweather and if
you want to take it a step further and
say I don't care the Nevada Commission
I've talked to people in the Nevada
Commission that's what if I would
probably be in Las Vegas there are
people in that Commission who have said
we're not going to sanction this why
would we sanction of a boxing match
between the best boxer in the world and
a guy that's never boxed before in his
life so put this people should put this
idea out of their heads because it's
just never gonna happen well you could
you know but have this in Dubai or
something and sanction it there they
could find a place for it I just think
yeah but yet but I mean that that's
that's even almost unrealistic to Dan
because you know when you have fights
overseas unless Dubai puts up two
hundred million dollars which I'm
skeptical they would ever do you lose a
massive on the pay-per-view yeah pay per
views have to be in the US um not
necessarily to be in a specific market
but they have to be in the u.s. to be
maximized I can't imagine this fight if
it ever happened we'll go anywhere else
but Las Vegas yeah I and I did laugh
when people say you know Conor McGregor
he's a good good boxer for an MMA
fighter I'm saying
it's one thing to anything like a good a
good at right a sumo wrestler is a great
goaltender a sumo wrestler I mean
doesn't they don't compute there's no
there's no correlation between an MMA
fighter and a professional boxer and
vice versa you've been on the road
covering the NBA yeah yeah just
following my Atlanta Hawks 1000 so might
white Howard you're you're Atlanta long
huh all in all in Atlanta are you
writing about them well you know it's
not your your your old atlanta hawks
I'll tell you that much I mean the
impact whites had there I mean it's been
noticeable I mean they are they went
from being you know in abysmal offensive
rebounding team to one of the best
offensive rebounding the way we can't be
we can't be discussed in the Hawks now
we can't that's enough they're not into
that the little leading me nothing
confident no no can't do it it's quite
who has who has teamed why twice in
front of the program I I had him on last
week I like to I know okay but that's
enough to talk for the Hawks for this
year who has a better record at the end
of the year the Timberwolves are the
lakers ah Timberwolves I think the
Wolves going to get better i think the
lakers are kind of playing above their
heads right now and they're going to
regress end of game situations the first
couple of weeks then have killed the
Timberwolves but if you're watching
under Wiggins last week 33 points per
game was last five I mean the
three-point shooting he's leading the
NBA in three-point shooting that's
probably an aberration yes but his
offensive game has come a long way I
think they're gonna get a lot better at
finishing games I think they'll be in
the playoff hunt at the end of the
season whereas the Lakers I don't see it
who has a more remarkable year Russell
Westbrook jr. the third or James Harden
you know I would probably say that stuff
they're both going to put up ridiculous
I missed a hardon because I've been more
impressed with what the Rockets have
done as a team that I have what what
Oklahoma City has done it when both
these guys their teams fall off a cliff
essentially when they step off the floor
but Oklahoma City has been really bad
when Westbrook has to come off the floor
I think hardens going to have you know
one of the most staggering point guard
type seasons in NBA history and he'll
wind up having a better year thank you
Chris safe travels thanks for joining us
you know you don't want to talk about
like Kyle Korver and what he
bring get a shorter get a shooter yes he
has yes you can get him really it's been
incredible bye dad thank you Chris the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience